we're hugely dependent on language to
help us express what we really think and
feel but some languages are better than
others but crisply naming important
feelings Germans have been geniuses at
inventing long or we'll get called
compound words that elegantly put a
finger on sensations that we all know
but that other languages require whole
clumsy sentences or paragraphs to
express so here is a small selection of
the best of Germany's extraordinary
range of compound words F cleon's nought
literally a distress
at not having an explanation the perfect
way to define what a partner might feel
when they're caught watching porn or
spotted in a restaurant with the hands
they shouldn't be holding more grandly
as clear Hung's nord is something we
feel when we realize we don't have any
explanations for the big questions of
life it's a word that defines
existential angst as much as shame for
tonight the feeling when you're eating
with other people and realize that
they've ordered something better off the
menu that you'd be dying to eat yourself
perhaps you were trying to be abstemious
now you're just starving the word
recognizes that we spend much of our
lives feeling we've ordered the wrong
thing and not just in restaurants your
loss literally a castle in the air a
dream that's unattainable a word
suggesting that German culture is deeply
indulgent about big dreams but also
gently realistic about how hard it can
be to bring them off but - guys eat a
face that's begging to be slapped
generosity towards others is key but
German is bracing and Hank enough to
acknowledge that there are also moments
when it's simply more honest to realize
we may have come face to face with a
[ __ ]
green and lust this word shows German at
its most delightfully fetishistic in
particular meaning the delight one can
feel at seeing ruin collapse palaces and
the rubble of temples but anxieties
about the present into perspective
and induce a pleasing melancholy at the
passage of all things commercial
literally sorrow fad a word that frankly
recognizes how often when one is deeply
sad there is simply nothing more
consoling to do than to head for the
kitchen and eat 10 Shaymin a word full
of empathy but captures the agony one
can feel if somebody else is
embarrassing misfortune or failure a
capacity to feel and chairman is a high
morale achievement and is at the root of
kindness belch melt literally world
sadness a word that acknowledges that we
are sometimes bad not about this or that
thing but about the whole basis of
existence the presence of the word
indicates a culture that isn't fourthly
cheerful that takes tragedy as a given
it is immensely reassuring to be able to
tell a friend that one is presently
lying under the duvet suffering from
vetch mouths shut and feyder
we're meant to be sad when others failed
the German more wisely accepts that we
often feel having coitus at the
misfortunes of Chardon of others that
isn't because we're mean we just feel
deeply reassured when we see
confirmation that life is as hard for
other people as it is us we can thank
German for having so many of the right
words to bring dignity to our troubles
and hopes learning languages ultimately
had little to do with discovering the
world per se it's about acquiring tools
to help us get a clearer grasp on the
elusive parts of our cell
you